في مهمه للايفاء بوعده في خفض قوارب
الهجره غير النظاميه متجاهلا احدث نتائج
استطلاع للراي وجد ان سته اشخاص من بين كل
عشره بريطانيين يعتقدون ان سوناك بصدد
الفشل في تحقيق وعوده لكن السوناك يرى
خلاف ذلك معددا خلال خطاب القاه من الجانب
الانجليزي لقناه عبور المهاجرين مؤشرات
نجاح خطته في وقف القوارب معلنا عن تراجع
نسبه عبور المهاجرين بعشرين في المائه
ما زال امامنا طريق طويل لكن منذ اطلاق
الخطه في الاشهر الخمسه الماضيه انخفضت
نسبه العبور بعشرين في المئه مقارنه
بالعام الماضي
بالاضافه الى جهوزيه سفينتين لاواء نحو
الف مهاجر غير قانوني وترحيل 1800 الباني
الى بلادهم ضمن اتفاق ابرمته الحكومه مع
البانيا
لقد اعدنا الان 1800 مهاجر الى البانيا في
غضون سته اشهر فقط
خطه السوناك وحكومه تواجه انتقادات عده في
مجلس اللوردات الذي يرى ان الخطه لا تلتفت
في جوهرها الى اخلاقيات التعامل مع
المهاجرين حجه ترى حكومه سوناك انها كلام
فقط ولا تقدم حلولا عمليه للتعامل او
احتواء ازمه المهاجرين
عقبات اخلاقيه وقانونيه يواجهها مشروع
قانون الهجره من سياسيين وطالبي لجوء
وحقوقيين وصفو سياسات الحكومه بالقاسيه
ولا تاخذ بالاعتبار اللاجئين
جزء كبير من مشروع قانون الهجره هو ببساطه
غير عملي والحكومه عمليا لن تكون قادره
على ازاله اعداد كبيره من الاشخاص لكن
السوناك افترض ان الهاربين من الموت او
التعذيب كما تزعم الروايات الالاف من
المهاجرين يعني انهم لن يمانعوا سياسات
ستبقيهم في امان على الاقل بحسب اعتباراته
من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات